Lawrence Kohlberg's theory claims that our development of moral reasoning happens in six stages.
The stages themselves are structured in three levels:
pre-conventional, conventional, and post-conventional
To understand this better, imagine a conflict at school
There is a fight in the schoolyard, two ninth-graders are beating up Tom
Those who watch the fight are at different stages of moral development
Let's see what they do and how they justify their behavior
At stage one, we make moral judgments based on obedience and punishment
Finn's sense of good or bad is directly linked to whether he gets punished or not
Finn sees what is happening to his friend and wants to help, but
he doesn't because he is afraid the teacher may punish him if he gets caught fighting
He asks himself, how can I avoid punishment?
At stage two, we are motivated by self-interest
Mary decides to intervene and help Tom
She knows that she might get punished,
but she also knows that she could become a victim herself someday
If she helps Tom now, he might help her in the future
She is asking herself: What's in it for me?
At stage three, interpersonal accord and conformity guide our moral judgment
Betty sees the fight and wants to intervene
But when she realizes that all the others are just watching, she decides not to get involved
She wants others to see that she is a good girl who is conforming with the ethics of the community
She asks herself: What do others think of me?
At stage four, we value authority and want to maintain social order
When the teacher sees the group fighting he immediately steps in and shouts: Stop! Fighting at school is forbidden!
He feels that, above all, it is important to follow the rules, otherwise chaos breaks out
He feels it is his duty to uphold the rules that sustain a functioning society
He asks himself: How can I maintain law and order?
At stage five, we understand rules as a social contract as opposed to a strict order
Jessie who watches from afar is not sure how she feels about this
To her, rules make sense only if they serve the right purpose
Obviously, the school rules prohibit fighting. But maybe Tom deserves to finally learn his lesson
Just yesterday he punched a young girl from grade one
She asks herself: Does a rule truly serve all members of the community?
At stage six, we are guided by universal ethical principles
All those involved now have to face the headmaster
He first explains the school rules and why they exist
He then clarifies that rules are valid only if they are grounded in justice
The commitment to justice carries with it an obligation to disobey unjust rules
The headmaster's highest moral principle is compassion
He believes that all people should learn to understand each other's viewpoints and that they don't feel alone with their feelings
He asks: What are the abstract ethical principles that serve my understandings of justice?
At the pre-conventional level, Finn is driven by fear and Mary by self-interest
Both judge what is right or wrong by the direct consequences they expect for themselves, and not by social norms
This form of reasoning is common among children
At the conventional level,
Betty responds to peer pressure and the teacher follows the rules
Their morality is centered around what society regards as right
At this level, the fairness of rules is seldom questioned
It is common to think like this during adolescence and adulthood
At the post-conventional level, Jesse knows that things are complicated because individuals may disobey rules inconsistent with their own morality
The headmaster follows a universal ethical idea at complete disconnect with what society thinks or the rules say
To him, everything is solved through compassion
The right behavior in his opinion is therefore never a means to an end, but always an end in itself
Not every person reaches this level
The American psychologist Lawrence Kohlberg based his work on Piaget's theory of cognitive development
In order to confirm his theory of stages of moral development
Kohlberg interviewed boys between the ages of 10 and 16
He analyzed how they would justify their decision when confronted with different hypothetical moral dilemmas
We will now present to you the most famous moral dilemma Kohlberg presented to his students
Let's see what you would do
The Heinz dilemma: A woman was on her deathbed
There was only one drug that the doctors thought might save her
The druggist that made that particular medicine sold it for ten times the price of the production costs
The sick woman's husband, Heinz, was poor and could not afford to buy the drug
not even with the financial help of his friends
Heinz then asked the pharmacist to sell it to him for half the price
But he refused
To save the life of his wife, Heinz broke into the man's laboratory and stole the medicine
Now tell us:
Should Heinz have stolen the drug?
Would it change anything if Heinz didn't love his wife?
What if the person dying was not his wife but a stranger?
Should the police arrest the druggist for murder if the wife had died?
Please write your answers and their justifications in the comments below
If you like this video and the way we explain the subject subscribe to our channel
We try to explain complex subjects in simple language and cartoons to support students all around the world in their learning
If you want to support us, you can go to www.patreon.com/sprouts and donate
Just $1 from many fans makes a big difference